There’s something out there, stalking, watching,
lying in wait for the right moment.
It can be anywhere, disappear in the blink
of an eye and reappear somewhere else, always
poised and ready to strike.
The SCP Foundation has it locked up for now;
they keep a tracking tag fixed to it so they
can find it whenever it gets out.
And believe us, it does get out.
So, when it does, you should watch your back,
keep your wits about you, and check over your
shoulder if you hear something move.
If you aren’t careful, it might come for
you.
If you let your guard slip, even just for
a second, you could be next…
Mclean, Virginia - It’s hardly a hotbed
of anomalous activity, Viola thought to herself
as she pulled up at the unassuming townhouse.
When she first joined the SCP Foundation,
Field Agent Smythe had imagined her life to
be full of adventure, battling anomalous monsters
and entities with the power to rewrite reality
itself.
Instead, she had unwittingly pulled a short
straw somewhere along the way, and now got
saddled with this: retrieving an anomaly that
had gone missing.
Viola had no idea what to expect, all she
had been told was that, according to its tracking
tag, the anomaly had teleported into one of
three Potential Relocation Sites, or PRSs.
She just happened to be the closest available
Field Agent station nearby, and was instructed
to drive over and collect it and return the
escaped SCP to the Foundation.
They had told Agent Smythe it was harmless,
putting her guard right down as she stepped
inside the house.
She wasn’t prepared for the ambush that
awaited her…
The house – codenamed PRS ‘Townhouse’
– was silent, practically abandoned as she
made her sweep.
Room by room, Viola was methodically checking
her corners, looking under beds, inside cupboards,
behind couches, on top of shelves, making
sure she’d covered every single inch of
the house.
Whatever this anomaly was, it was good at
hiding.
Before long, Agent Smythe had checked the
whole house from top to bottom and had found
nothing, no sight of the elusive SCP.
With no idea where it was, Viola went into
the kitchen; she figured she might as well
see if there was anything to eat in this place.
Maybe it had already gone, she thought; she’d
have to check in with base, and see if the
tracking tag was still active at this location.
This thing could teleport, after all, it could
be sunbathing in Cancun by now, drinking a
Pina Colada out of a coconut with a tiny umbrella.
Oh, wouldn’t that be the life…
Viola approached the refrigerator and casually
placed her hand on the door.
With no idea what was waiting for her inside,
she pulled it open… and was immediately
hit in the face with a pillow.
It wasn’t traveling at any substantial speed,
in fact, it was like it had been lightly thrown
by a human hand more than anything else.
It didn’t knock Field Agent Smythe back
or send her reeling, or have enough force
to cause any injury.
Instead, the pillow just softly impacted Viola’s
face, giving a little ‘squeak’ like a
dog toy would before it lazily fell onto the
kitchen floor.
Fixed to one side of it was a post-it note
with a crudely drawn face that glared up at
her with a jagged frown.
Viola sighed, mildly annoyed that she’d
just had a pillow thrown at her now, after
having spent a half-hour searching the house.
Leaning down, she picked it up, and radioed
the Foundation; she’d found SCP-3832.
But it didn’t end there, oh no.
After they got the anomaly safely back in
its containment locker, it wasn’t long before
the Foundation was soon inundated with more
pillowy pandemonium.
Nobody was safe from being the next victim
of a sudden ambush by SCP-3832, not even a
harmless, unassuming researcher like Doctor
Franklin Prangley.
He had just been going about his day, checking
containment procedures were all in place,
running tests on a few SCPs, the usual stuff
for a scientist working at Site 64.
That was when the call went out over the comms
system: it had happened again, SCP-3832 had
vanished from the locker it was usually kept
secure in.
While, on the outside, it looked like little
more than an ordinary cushion, this anomaly
was the ultimate hunter, displaying behavior
almost exactly like that of various highly
evolved ambush predators in the wild.
And now, this hunter was loose again, and
it was open season on the Foundation staff.
This time, it hadn’t gone far, having only
teleported to a different part of Site 64.
As he would soon discover, the cunning cushion
was hiding just above Doctor Prangley’s
locker, waiting for the researcher to return
to his office.
Then, when he was close enough, SCP-3832 would
strike.
But the next would-be victim of the predatory
pillow had an advantage.
The location tracking tag that the Foundation
had affixed to the pillow proved to be its
downfall, giving Prangley an approximate fix
on its whereabouts.
Gently pushing his office door open, he instantly
spotted it on the top of his office locker,
ready to pounce on him the moment he got close
enough.
Slowly and methodically, Doctor Prangley edged
around his office, reaching for a meterstick
he kept by his desk.
With his chosen weapon in hand, the Foundation
researcher stepped closer to his locker, eyes
fixed on SCP-3832.
He was brandishing the wooden meterstick in
both hands, carrying it like an early caveman
with a hand-crafted spear.
At that moment, Doctor Franklin Prangley was
locked in the dichotomy between predator and
prey, that age-old dance, a battle that had
raged for almost all of time itself: man versus
pillow.
We’ve all been there, haven’t we?
Suddenly, striking first, Franklin took a
sharp swipe at SCP-3832 with his meterstick.
He broke out with a smile of glee as the pillow
was toppled from its vantage point; it no
longer had the high ground over him.
Employing a swift offense as the best defense,
the noble Doctor Prangley had felled SCP-3832
in one quick, pre-emptive strike… or so
he thought.
As the old saying goes, “Pride goeth before
the fall.”
No sooner had it landed in a heap on the office
floor, than SCP-3832 launched itself back
up and limply hit Franklin square in the stomach.
He let out a low grunt as the pillow connected
with his lower abdomen, and squeaked again,
announcing to the world that SCP-3832 had
just claimed its latest victim.
Dr. Prangley might never get over that particular
humiliation.
If he’s eaten by SCP-682 in a week, it will
be a merciful reprieve.
No one could end this crafty cushion’s reign
of terror, to stand against this goose feather-filled
hunter was to risk certain death…
well, death by embarrassment, at least.
Which some would argue is honestly worse.
Security Officer Jennifer Blaire was never
the same after it happened to her.
It was waiting for her behind the coffee machine
in the Site 64 break room.
She’d gone in there for a quick cup, just
to recharge her energy levels with a boost
of caffeine before getting back to her post
guarding the containment level.
Poor Jen, she never saw it coming.
SCP-3832 leaped from its latest hiding place,
striking Officer Blaire right in her unprotected
ankle.
The sudden, vicious attack from the polyester
cover-wearing persecutor caught her completely
unguarded, which was somewhat ironic for a
member of the Foundation’s security personnel.
But Security Officer Jennifer Blake had no
time to laugh at the irony there.
Punctuated by that same squeaking sound, the
sudden impact of the pillow colliding with
her ankle caused her to stumble.
Not fall, mind you, she only lost balance
on one leg and was able to quickly steady
herself immediately after.
But it was enough, just enough… for her
coffee to spill!
If you need a moment to compose yourself after
that horrifying revelation, we’d understand,
it’s one of the more disturbing things we’ve
shared on this normally family-friendly channel.
Leave a comment with the key phrase “#JusticeForJen”
so this poor SCP Foundation security officer
knows she’s in your thoughts and prayers
after this harrowing incident.
Everyone okay now?
Good.
Back to the story at hand.
The incident caused Jen to suffer a few minor
first-degree burns on her hand and wrist,
requiring a fifteen-minute treatment in the
Site 64 infirmary - which the medic described
as “The worst relatively minor burns I’ve
ever seen.”
While her external injuries might not have
taken much time to heal, now Officer Blake
has to bring instant coffee from home to work
in a thermos flask.
Can you imagine such horror?
It stretches the human imagination to even
compensate for the level of terror it inspires
in our hearts and souls.
Everywhere you looked, Site 64 staff were
being struck down left, right, and center,
mildly inconvenienced without warning by non-lethal
and mostly harmless ambushes from SCP-3832.
During another relocation incident, the predatory
pillow teleported itself back to the location
known as PRS Townhouse in Mclean, Virginia.
Once again, Field Agent Viola Smythe was dispatched
to the scene to retrieve the elusive pillow,
only this time, she had learned from her last
encounter: she’d brought backup.
Specifically, one other Field Officer, named
Gordon Gompton, to hopefully give the cunning
cushion its critical comeuppance.
Both field agents knew one of them would have
to take the hit, and Gordon stepped up to
the task.
After all, it had already got Viola once before.
It was his turn to face the nightmare that
was SCP-3832 head-on.
They entered the townhouse, Agent Gompton
taking the lead, acting as a human shield
against any oncoming pillowy projectiles.
Just as they expected, and as it had before,
the ambush took place not long after, with
SCP-3832 ineffectively hurling itself from
its hiding place.
But, at the last possible second, Gordon ducked
out of the way.
It was purely instinctive, but it left Viola
at the mercy of the oncoming cushion.
It was a betrayal of truly Shakespearian proportions,
playing out in real-time.
Marginally vexed at being hit a second time
with the pillow, Agent Smythe immediately
decided to claim her well-earned revenge.
Grabbing the nearest safe object, which happened
to be SCP-3832 itself, she hurled it directly
at her fellow field operative.
It collided with his head with another ‘squeak’,
the combined sight and sound causing Viola
to burst out laughing.
Wearing a crafty smirk, Gordon grabbed the
pillow and threw it back at her, the same
thing happening.
The pair of them kept at it, repeatedly throwing
SCP-3832 at each other again and again, every
time the same squeaking filled the air, followed
by more laughing from the two agents.
As they continued their pillow fight, SCP-3832
underwent a change that nobody at the SCP
Foundation had ever witnessed before.
With every throw, hitting either Agent Smythe
or Agent Gompton with its characteristic squeaking
noise, the face drawn on the post-it note
that was permanently stuck to SCP-3832 began
to change.
Usually, the sticky paper depicted a jagged,
hand-drawn, frowny face; an upturned mouth
and eyebrows pointing inward in attack formation.
A truly terrifying countenance to behold.
It also turned out that it was impossible
to remove the post-it without causing the
pillow to teleport again.
However, while it was being thrown about,
used in a pillow fight between two Foundation
field agents, joining in a rare moment of
childlike joy, the face of SCP-3832 began
to change.
The frown was replaced with the unmistakable
curvature of a smile, those angry attack eyebrows
completely vanishing as the pillow was pleasantly
pelted from Agent Viola Smythe to Agent Gordon
Gompton.
Eventually, after they’d had their fun,
the two operatives were duty-bound to return
the now-grinning cushion to Foundation.
They reported their findings to researchers,
many of whom seemed eager to take part in
tests replicating this incident, either because
they were looking to blow off some steam with
a nice, wholesome pillow fight, or because
they wanted to make SCP-3832 smile again.
It didn’t take long for the fearsome piece
of feather-filled furniture to get back to
its old tricks though.
After all, you can’t teach an old pillow
new tricks.
And as for its next, unsuspecting victim?
The next would be none other than the Director
of Site 64 himself, one Edgar Holman.
That’s right, not even one of the highest-ranked
members of Foundation staff stationed at that
particular facility was exempt from falling
prey to the dreaded pillow.
Having once again disappeared from the confines
of its locker, SCP-3832 subsequently concealed
itself under the desk in Director Holman’s
office, laying in wait to pounce at its prey.
As he pulled up his chair to sit down, the
site director was met with a soft, cushiony
impact to his shins; any further up and it
could’ve caused serious damage, he was lucky
that dastardly pillow didn’t crease his
well-ironed slacks!
Then there was the relocation event that became
known as Incident 3832-NR1.
A few key differences set this particular
occurrence apart from the others on SCP-3832’s
calamitous cacophony of concealed cushion
carnage.
For one, it is what directly led to the first
of a few rare instances where the post-it-faced
pillow teleported itself to a location now
known as PRS ‘Truffle’, the designation
given to St John’s Chocolate Factory in
Portland, Oregon.
Why a Saint had a chocolate factory, we may
never know.
But I digress.
Since becoming a Potential Relocation Site
that SCP-3832 is able to transport itself
to, the factory had to be seized by the SCP
Foundation.
Where it had once offered tours to the public
to present them with all the wonders of the
sweet-toothed process of making chocolate,
the gates now remained closed, with the false
promise that St John’s Chocolate Factory
was ‘Under New Management’, keeping people
out.
Entire floors that could easily be accessed
by someone trying to swipe a sample or two
have now been completely cleared out by the
Foundation, with not a stick of furniture
left in the place for anyone to steal, or
for SCP-3832 to hide behind.
On the fourteenth of February, St Valentine’s
Day, 2017, Foundation technicians had been
working on repairing a glitch that had been
disrupting SCP-3832’s tracking tag.
It was during that moment that the wily, polyester
pillow teleported out of its locker at Site
64 once again, vanishing and reappearing in
the trunk of a car belonging to a member of
personnel.
Now, for security reasons, the name of this
staff member has been censored, letting her
retain her anonymity… and probably whatever
is left of her dignity too.
We’ll just call her Big Sister, which is
how the file on the highly classified SCP
Archive refers to her.
Up until this point, the researchers at the
SCP Foundation had never known SCP-3832 to
have the ability to teleport into a moving
vehicle.
Teleportation is hard enough at the best of
times; seriously; you try shifting every atom
of your body from one spot to another without
getting stuck in a wall.
And yet, the crafty cushion made the switch
effortlessly, relocating itself into the back
of Big Sister’s car without her noticing.
And to her credit, she had other things on
her mind.
She’d just finished a long day’s work
at Site 64, and she still needed to pick something
up for a special someone; it was Valentine’s
Day after all.
As she drove away, Big Sister was completely
oblivious to the fact that SCP-3832 could
apparently now teleport itself into moving
vehicles.
The research team studying the pillow and
even the security staff she passed at the
front gate were equally unaware.
Making her way further and further from Site
64, Big Sister pulled onto the freeway, nervously
checking her watch.
She desperately hoped she could get there
in time before the factory closed, and that
they’d still have a box left.
They had to, right?
Who sells out of chocolate on Valentine’s
Day?
It’s their biggest sales day of the year,
save for perhaps Easter Sunday.
Getting closer to St John’s Chocolate Factory,
Big Sister could see from a distance that
the lights were still on.
She relaxed in the driver’s seat, breathing
a sigh of relief that she’d made it in good
time.
Her thoughts quickly turned to her sweetheart,
imagining the look of delight on their face
when she got home and presented them with
a shiny, heart-shaped box, filled with a delicious
assortment of confectionaries.
Parking up, she dashed inside, the last person
in before closing time.
Little did she know what was still lurking
in the trunk of her car - like the urban legend
of the ax-wielding killer in the backseat.
With her romantic holiday gesture of a box
of chocolates all paid for and tucked securely
under her arm, Big Sister made her way back
to the car.
Then, a thought struck her, a terrible thought…
she couldn’t just leave this in the car!
The surprise would be totally ruined if her
significant other could see what she’d got
for them.
There was only one thing for it, the box of
chocolates needed to be hidden when she got
home, and where else do you think to hide
something in a car?
In the trunk, of course.
As Big Sister unlocked the back and lifted
up the trunk lid, a concealed cushion stealth
attack of pure pillow force struck her.
SCP-3832 launched itself from its hiding place,
only to collide with the box that Big Sis
was carrying, catching her completely by surprise.
Making its signature squeak, the predatory
pillow knocked the box sharply upwards into
the air and, in a cruel twist of fate, sent
the pointed edge of the heart straight into
Big Sister’s face.
The tapered tip was propelled straight into
her mouth, chipping her front tooth, as SCP-3832
landed on the ground of the parking lot.
It was the most brutally violent attack that
SCP-3832 had ever conducted, shocking everyone
at the SCP Foundation with its sheer wanton
ferocity.
Making a call to the SCP Foundation, Big Sister
requested a recovery team to come and collect
the troublesome cushion; after picking up
the present for her Valentine and the fragment
of her tooth it had rather unceremoniously
knocked out.
Sighing, she leaned against the rear bumper
of her car, keeping an eye on SCP-3832 while
she waited for the recovery team to arrive.
What a way to spend Valentine’s Day, Big
Sister thought to herself, worried about what
her partner would say when she got home late
with a chipped tooth.
Then she noticed something that, while it
didn’t fix the situation, at least made
her feel a little less bad about it.
The post-it note face of SCP-3832 had changed
once again.
Big Sister grabbed her phone from her pocket
to take a picture of it so she could hand
it over as evidence to the research team.
Instead of its normal frown scribbled across
the sticky note, SCP-3832’s hand-drawn expression
had become an almost bashful, dimpled smile,
with a big pair of cartoon hearts in its eyes.
So, if you take anything away from this video,
it should be this gentle reminder.
The chances of you being ambushed and pounced
upon by pillow with a post-it note for a face
are…
well, statistically speaking, the chances
are pretty slim, But they’re never zero
either.
You really should keep your wits about you,
stay alert, make sure you check for movement
when you leave every room, and look under
tables and even in your refrigerator just
to be safe.
And if you see something moving, out of the
corner of your eye, even just for a split
second… then you too might just get hit
in the face by a pillow.
Now, why not go and check out “SCP-999:
THE TICKLE MONSTER” and “SCP-348 A GIFT
FROM DAD” to get yourself acquainted with
a few of the more adorable anomalies that
the SCP Foundation have encountered!